what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
when I first moved to Colorado uh when
my pods container arrived everything
inside of it was totally shredded I mean
he was absolutely trashed like my TV was
smashed my desk was smashed never use
pod shipping and storage I tweeted it
all out on Twitter because I tried to
call their customer service and they
just kept sending me to voicemail I just
started posting images and hanging them
on Twitter and it took about ten images
for them to finally like respond and I
was like okay cool well you know I'm
gonna advise everybody to never use your
service again but they totally trashed
my my PC it was a it was this massive
beast of a PC but I was up until 5:45 in
the morning yesterday finally getting it
all sorted out it only took three months
to do it to GTX 1080 T eyes later a new
new reservoir pump and two new
reservoirs systems refilled the B C's
all put back together again I am happy I
am I'm very satisfied at the moment so
yeah never use pods shipping and storage
anyway what's going on guys this is Rob
and as you all know our Omega beyond
Omega level series is designed to
showcase the powers and origins of some
of the most powerful characters to ever
exist in the history of comic books
sometimes we pull jokes where we do like
pickle rick from rick and morty
but more often than not it's just a
character who existed in some form or
fashion over the course of Marvel DC and
valiant scum about history and we
showcase how powerful they are in this
video we are going to take a break from
superheroes in the traditional sense and
we're gonna focus on what I consider to
be the most powerful force and comic
books that's right you guys the rock or
my fans now as we always do we need to
focus on the origin of the robbed core
and then we'll get into an explanation
of what the robbed core is capable of
now while the robbed core would not
formally come into existence until
December of 2013 they could actually
trace its beginnings back further than
that to a time when a man with a passion
for Marvel Comics and a desire to share
his knowledge with others was struck by
a spark of inspiration largely inspired
by seananners in the following months he
would make a decision to use the
widespread popularity of the Internet in
an attempt to reach those who had a
desire to bolster their knowledge of the
Marvel Universe to that end this guy me
created a video explaining a pretty
obscure mutant named jason wyngarde
uploaded it and crossed my fingers
hoping for the best it was in the
response to this video that the
power of the rod poor was first revealed
although not yet formally organized many
of the individuals that would go on to
comprise the rod poor would find their
way to this video either through a
stroke of luck on youtube search engine
or posts on the vast internet form known
as Reddit because I spam that website a
lot that I did it hoping people would
watch my videos and they did now
throughout the coming months and years
the Rob core would grow in number and an
influence while you guys originally came
seeking content you guys soon began
shaping it through your influence in the
comments section on the videos that were
featured on this channel then known as
marvel explain anyway covering only
Marvel Universe content as membership of
the Rob core increased however so did
your all's desire for knowledge and
eventually craving information from
beyond the boundaries of the Marvel
Universe and demanded the channel began
covering characters and concepts from
the DC Universe as well now because of
the extreme power that you guys wield
man I'm making you guys out to be
absolutely monsters because of the power
you guys wield we were able to transform
the Marvel explain channel to the comics
explain channel as our scope began to
expand to include comics from not only
Marvel but DC Image valiant and others
fun fact I once covered a story called
Jesus hates zombies it's amazing you
guys really need to check it out so in a
world where there is a seemingly endless
supply of youtubers covering all
different kinds of content each with
their own respective fan bases what is
it that sets the robbed core apart and
makes you guys truly beyond omega-level
well first and over 1.1 million strong
at the time that this video is being
recorded the robbed core is among the
most numerous in the entire youtube
comic book community and honestly that
statistic alone is unbelievable the fact
that you guys have put up with me for
four years with all my waxing and waning
in the times when I wanted to quit and
all that kind of stuff is astounding
it's astounding to me you guys have
outlasted some of my girlfriend's like
just think about that I have a better
rapport with you then I did with the
women that I dated how pitiful is that
in addition to this the rob course
desire for knowledge matches that of any
other fan base for any other common book
youtuber out there in fact when the Rob
core officially formed you
created an out for yourself that
highlighted your quest for common book
knowledge
I held a contest on my channel I said
I'm hosting a contest to form a Rob Koro
and the winner gets to actually have
that oath and the oath of the Rob core
as amazing as it is from pages small to
screen of bright know comics shall
escape my sight let those who choose a
side and fight beware the power of the
Rob Coors Light yes that is the winning
of the greatest Lantern oath ever now
once this oath is recited a member of
the Rob core will receive the gray power
ring which comes with its own set of
abilities which are powered by the
knowledge of its where exactly how the
Green Power Ranger Ahsan will power and
the Red Lantern ring draws on rage
fun fact when I went to New York
comic-con and I told people I was giving
away Rob core rings that place was a
madhouse dudes one of the craziest
things ever most overwhelming things
ever I brought everybody outside of the
room and I was like all right guys I
can't think of a better place to do this
so we're just gonna start handing out
Rob for rings you would have thought I
was Jesus healing people's kids they
were like people like hands everywhere
I'm just grabbing rings and putting them
into hands I showed up with 45 rings
there were 200 people there I was like
huh so I guess the next time I go to New
York Comic Con next year or the next con
I go to I'll have to show up with like
500 rings hoping that you know I have
enough for people who with 500 rings
surely I should have enough for people
but that'll be a whole bunch of stuff do
either that or I can just tack it on to
the store to like set up a whole store
sell merchandise and tack the rings on
and then just sell the Rings that way I
hate not being able to give you guys
rings but regardless in addition to
creating hardlight constructs of the
gray variety an individual wielding the
Rob pour ring will be able to know all
past and present events going on
throughout the universe as well as the
powers and abilities of anyone involved
in those events pretty cool huh I like
that little tidbit when it comes to what
the Rob port can do so while the Rob
core ring does not allow its user to
predict the future
it basically bestows all the knowledge
available at any given time to its where
there are however weaknesses inherent to
the robbed war for example the sheer
amount of knowledge available to members
of the Rob for
must be constantly kept in check by the
concentration of it's where otherwise
the wearer's focus is broken and they'll
be overwhelmed by their vast knowledge
and driven insane I mean a person can
only really know so much about Mad Jim
Jasper's before they're driven mad
themselves if a member of the rob court
becomes arrogant because of their
advanced knowledge their hardlight
constructs will become progressively
weaker as their arrogance grows
I'm ashamed to say I if the robbed poor
we had robbed four rings like two years
ago I would have lost mine immediately I
was man I was in the right state like
two years ago it was pitiful I thought I
was the center of the universe
just ask comics Torian now if their
arrogance reaches a certain point
however the robbed core ring will
abandon its user entirely and seek out a
host with more humility so where does
the ring draw the line at what point do
you cross this line where your ring will
leave you well I'm not sure it's ever
really happened but I think it's just
beyond the point where people start
posting really condescending comments on
videos about scientists turning
themselves into pickles once you get
beyond that you're probably flirting
with the ring leaving you in all
seriousness though casting aside joking
and all that kind of stuff one of the
things we always do on our beyond
omega-level video is look at some of the
feats of our subject and the rock core
has what I think is the most impressive
feat of all because of you guys I was
able to go from working a job as a
dispatcher that I did not particularly
enjoy I loved the people there but the
job itself was was a little more than I
was beginning to be able to handle I
went from being able to work that job to
being able to make videos about what it
is that I loved about comic books and
talking to you guys about comic books I
mean how crazy is that you know and it's
entirely because of you guys because of
the fact that you watch my videos it's
because of the work that my editor puts
in and putting them together it's
because of the work that Ryan my writer
puts in and writing the script it's
because of the work that my database
manager does with it my you know that
Shawn does and making really good wine
it's all because of this this huge
effort this huge undertaking that
everybody goes through in order to make
this channel successful but all of it
would be for naught if you guys never
watched anything and so this video is
really a tribute to you guys a tribute
to my fans a tribute to everybody who
helped me to get to where I am
now because without you guys it wouldn't
be possible you know so while I would
love to take credit for everything well
I would like to say that I'm the reason
why everything's successful I'm not I'm
just one cog in a very very very large
wheel that serves the purpose of making
the Commerce explained channel move in a
forward direction
I mean imagine what it would be like if
comics explained wasn't here imagine
what it would be like if comics
explained didn't exist well then you
know we'd all have to get our comic book
content broken down into digestible
rights and read dramatically back to you
and what kind of a world would that be
Benny
hashtag comics Torian sucks so well this
may have seemed like a weird video
concept when it showed up in your
subscription feed the real reason I made
this video is just to thank you guys
again just to say you guys are amazing
you know you guys are supportive it's
super cool to read your comments the
ones who aren't being jerks to people it
really is awesome to kind of see you
guys help my channel grow and help me
get to where it is there's no landmark
moment coming up it's not like I'm
quitting I just felt like making a video
that would be a tribute to you guys so
again basically thank you and like for
those of you guys who are new hit the
sub button become part of the Rob core
and like a million people were told 1.1
million people were told of fact before
you you have the desire to know all
things
welcome to the Rob core when that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end and I guess I could say it
again if you are new here to commerce
explain but make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]